hello world out there happy corn times
to you hope you're staying safe and
healthy here's some weirdness that may
bring a smile to your face
I'm here with BuzzFeed reading thirst
tweets let's do it I'm jealous of Darren
Criss bc which means because not before
christ is commonly misunderstood I'm
jealous of Darren Criss b/c Darren Criss
gets to touch Darren Criss but Darren
Criss such as Darren Criss but all the
time whether out of necessity or just
out of fun it sits there everybody has a
a right and a similarity to touch their
own butt and you're making me feel
better about it than I that I ever have
so yeah I'm doing it right now
just hitting it hear that sound that's
the sound of me smacking my own but it's
just a bud remember poop comes out of it
there is nothing more important to me
then Darren Chris's sweaty collarbone I
should hope there are more important
things to you than a sweaty collarbone
your taxes hygiene may be learning a
foreign language but I don't know your
background maybe maybe you've figured
those things out already I should try
and be sweaty more often this is not
really a statement it just says Darren
Chris's ass Darren Criss asks Darren
Criss has a big ass do have a big ass
I've been really like because there are
people who like say I have like they
know they have big ass I I don't like
spend hours staring at my butt so I
don't know what's going on there so I
haven't really put a whole lot of
investigation into that I love Darren
Criss so much that it hurts when I pee
haha I like I like that as a qualify for
anything you like I like something so
much that when I urinate there's there's
pain Darren Criss is my Buzzi whisperer
oh that is that's wonderful I love that
that's hilarious these are things that
genuinely tickle me
we must call upon the [ __ ] whisperer
there's only one man we must call Darren
he's the only [ __ ] whisperer from Myles
and I go to the [ __ ] and I just I'm
honored to be your ghost whisperer um
clears throat this is an action to stage
director Darren Chris's thighs and then
back it back into the parentheses
crowd cheers what's cool about this I
guess the the writer in me is trying to
think of the infinite scenarios where
this could be
a scene where like Darren Chris's thighs
being the line is the victory like maybe
I'm at a chicken bake-off and I have
somehow you know made some like dope ass
like fried chicken thighs and we're all
sitting there and there's like the final
three and the winner is
Darren Krista's thighs crowd goes Abel I
want a Darren Criss stamp then I could
lick his face without looking weird if
the stamp was an adhesive where the
imagery was on the side was on the other
side then you'd be able to accomplish
that if my face is here then you'd be
licking the inside of my face so the
only other way that you could maybe
accomplish this is if you were to rip my
face off and sort of like you know whip
it out like a towel and then lick it
from the inside but that might be a
little more hard and a little more
illegal and a little more dangerous to
me and my livelihood and my loved ones
Darren Criss you don't know me but I
dream of fondling your nipples
okay okay XO thank you for checking in
with me I'm I'm flattered that I've made
it into your dreams dream on sista dream
on brother I don't know what I'm talking
to so not it's I don't care who it is
gender wise but I hope that I hope it
was a good dream I've been staring at
that pic of Darren Criss all day and it
makes me get the [ __ ] butterflies God
[ __ ] have really like turned up a lot
of [ __ ] representation I'm very happy
for the busty community I want to
dry-hump Darren Chris's jawline I don't
know if my jawline wants to dry-humping
you so I have to check in with my
jawline to make sure that there's sort
of a consensual interest I will check in
with you I'll check in with his people
and see if we can make this happen
listen guys here's the deal I am the
creator and producer writer songwriter
actor of this show that I created called
royalties which is a really scrappy zany
wacky little short form comedy that we
made for kwibi which you may might not
be familiar with which is a new short
form content platforms for your phone
Thank You BuzzFeed for having me and I
will see you again when I'm trolling all
of the comments on this video
[Music]